hello Russ don't mind me I'm just having
a Sunday Drive I just wanted to show you
my goddamn penis Oh how's the girl
breast my favorite and welcome to turbo
dismount I've been [ __ ] around with
this game a little bit it's really funny
so the goal of the game I don't know
what it is I guess going from point A to
point B and you can change your vehicle
you can change the obstacles you can
change poses which is like the most
genius thing ever
he looks so happy he doesn't need a
steering wheel
Oh mak'st oh haha
like the point is to get like rekt as
much as possible and get point from that
that is that isn't oh how do you even do
that I didn't notice that his butt is
literally in the front you can watch
himself take a [ __ ] that's like every
man's dream wait what was his name left
side boom a sir okay okay side boob go
make that ass [ __ ] market oh [ __ ] it's
gonna hurt Oh God
what are you okay there side boob he's
fine
it's fine I think there's some weird
kinky [ __ ] going on with him in the car
I don't know what your eyes car cool
that does not look comfortable side boob
how does he hold on go side boob ah
I think he's jerking off the car oh it
could fall off it could fall off oh I
was just aa car buy go side boob Oh Oh
God side to boobie you're crazy man
ain't no bottle [ __ ] go go go go go go
go go go go side boob power Oh take a
detour there we go Oh God Oh God
I he's praying
don't kill me please huh ah come on what
is he doing
ah all right finally let's try this with
the shopping cart I don't see how this
would work how am I even going forward
nail it
that front flap come on come on come on
please please he's fine he's fine
Bobby's sticking in that you're not
supposed to sleep while driving quick
barb it's dangerous Bob you're not
supposed to you're led to your leg drive
God it's dangerous that is not how you
sit well okay Bob you decide that's what
happened all right what about here the
twerking position yes of course let's
get a good angle on this ass Park for me
Bob ah yay Oh Bob why would you hang
there this is perfect he'll drive around
them or not Billy Bob really you think
that's a good haha oh oh [ __ ] oh oh oh
[ __ ] he's holding on ha ha ha ha nice is
holding oh god you're not gonna like
this Bob I'm sorry and maybe you do I
don't know what you into front flap come
on baby you can do it Bob
I think he died No oh gee lost his foot
Oh
can you jump over it nope Oh
oh my god no aha
let's ride another map man Bob has a
great ass Oh
O'Shea look at Oh
oh come on just a regular today go into
work
I like how you jiggle it mmm sexy I
think Bob invented twerking it'll be
fine Bob it's great idea trust me Bob
I've done this before
Oh [ __ ] slow it is and it will all be
fine
I won't be fine I'm sorry I changed my
mind you're gonna die Bob Oh fear is the
enemy here nothing else and those cars
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
well the car made it hey what's up pants
no big deal I'm just hanging him I don't
trust your pants
I don't guys go check yeah you're right
don't make out with girls if you were to
have a dick Mellet what happened wait
what what are you doing go Bob
you made it we made it we [ __ ] made
it look at that [ __ ] can just be brave
Bob hold your breath and you might live
I don't know how it will change anything
Oh
No oh is that his answer is face this
might just be fine
you never know actually not it's not
it's not fine trust me on this one this
is the one I know we all have our dubs
when things aren't gonna work the wind
may misjudge some situations nail it
sure it's all gonna be all gone oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god don't work if you don't have
an ad let's try the space program if you
don't try then you probably won't die
hey you slogan for this game really I
can put obstacles there oh [ __ ] that
doesn't work okay let's do it
you have a nice ass that will get you
far in life don't worry about it
probably not to space [ __ ] Bob nope
Bob is gone
if only I could sit next to you Bob
every guy here we go here we go here we
go
come on hang on yes oh [ __ ]
don't worry Bob you'll be fine I swear I
swear to God don't don't even think
about not trusting me Bob died with
honor look at that I always wanted my
leg coming out of my deck yeah it's
[ __ ] ads mmm ohh ohh ohh aah what the
[ __ ] is happening here
let's have yeah go Bob don't let you all
stop you okay maybe maybe you should
they told Bob Bob couldn't go to space
first Bob outside then Bob cried then
Bob I don't know what he's doing there
we go go to space Bob you go to space
make me proud nope that is not the
direction of space man that's sexy
finish
alright Prez that's all the time I had
for today
turbo a discipline it's pretty fun game
you can check it out for free if you
want to I'll leave a link in the
description it subscribe I come with
today I see brothers in the next video
stay on some res love you my hat
you